on problem 16 problem 16 actually draw
the axes that's the x-axis y-axis
there's a parabola drawing tool year but
there isn't there's a parabola it looks
something like this something like this
they tell us this is the point one this
point one fair enough this is of course
the y-axis that's the x-axis the figure
above shows the graph of a quadratic
function H whose maximum values age of
two so this is its maximum value right
here when x is equal to 22 maximum is H
of to each of two right there if H of a
is equal to 0 H of a is equal to zero so
a so where is this function equals zero
it function equals zero two places here
and here right it's Y value is zero and
those two places so this could be a or
that could be a we don't know which of
the following could be a so we're saying
this could be a or this could be a we
don't know and we know that this is too
so a is either going to be greater than
2 or less than is less than zero or
actually actually we can actually figure
out what a is right because these if
this is the maximum point it's going to
be symmetric around the point to right
so the distance from two day on this
side has to be the same as the distance
from 2 to the end this and actually that
doesn't help us so let's look at the
choices a could be negative 1 right that
looks fair because it's less than less
than 0 a can't be 0 0 is this point let
me pick colors that's 0 that's
definitely not where you intersect they
draw it so you can't be there can't be
two because that's actually where the
maximum point is so egg definitely isn't
too can a be three and this is where the
symmetry comes into play right we know
that it does not intersect the x-axis
for at least on the left hand side you
go one two and then some distance which
we don't really know what you're going
more than two on this side right
so you're also going to go more than two
on this side you're going to go one two
and then some distance right so this is
two three four so you know that a has to
be less than 0 less than zero or a has
to be greater than four and if you look
at all of the choices the only I mean
only negative 1 is less than zero all
none of the other ones are greater than
4 and how did I know greater than 4
because it's symmetric if this is if
this is the maximum point at two and one
of the places where I intersect the
x-axis is more than two to the left the
other place where I intersect the x-axis
has to be more than two to the right so
it has to be greater than for this has
to be less than zero this has to be
greater than four and that's the answer
negative one next problem and you really
didn't have to you know once you've felt
comfortable at negative 1 you can just
said well that's the answer right
because you could very easily have
intersected the x-axis that x equals
negative 1 problem 17 that was the first
choice which tends to be convenient let
me make it a brighter color problem 7 if
K and H are constants and x squared plus
K X plus 7 is equivalent to it equals x
plus 1 times X plus h what is the value
of K well at first slide it doesn't seem
like we could solve this but maybe we
can let's try x squared plus KX plus 7
is equal to x squared plus X plus X plus
plus h x plus h x plus h and so this
equals x squared what's 1 X right x is
same thing as 1 X what's 1 x plus HX
well that's 1 plus h x plus h right I
just combine these two terms i added
their coefficients and we say that x
squared plus KX plus then oh well
actually maybe we can't solve this right
because we can just match up terms we
say the corphish this term
this term matches up to this term this
term matches up to that term so we know
H is equal to 7 and if h is equal to 7
what is this term equal to that term is
going to be equal to 7 plus 1 is 8 right
and this term what does this term match
up two matches up to this we're just
kind of matching coefficients if this is
eight then k is equal to a and that's
choice D at first I was a cobham i got
to solve this that's why you should
always just kind of move forward and see
if you see any patterns next problem
problem 18 problem 18
okay y X and they draw a line here
something like that to go from A to C
flat line and then you go up like this
oh hi the line keeps going and then
there's the point up here which is the
point which is the point here this is 4
comma 10 so this is 10 and this is for
this is a b c and the figure above if
the legs of triangle ABC are parallel to
the axes right this is parallel to that
this is parallel to that so this is
going to be a right angle which of the
following could be the lengths of the
sides of ABC interesting so this is
really just a slope problem because what
they wanted to do is figure out the
ratio of this side to this side so what
is the slope of this line what is the
slope of this line well it rot rose 10
change in Y over change in X this is
what am i doing over change in X is
equal to all right 10-0 which is 10 /
4-0 which is for that equals 5 5 over 2
so for everyone it moves to the right
it's going to go 5 over 2 up so if this
is X this is going to be 5 over 2x right
so first we should look for the two
shorter sides are going to have this
ratio you know 125 over 2 so if you look
at the first choice choice A two and
five if this is too if x is equal to two
then if x is 2 then what's two times
five over too well though this will be
five right that'll be five so that
satisfies that ratio and you could even
figure out you know rise is 5 when run
is to which is a slope of 5 over 2 and
now we just got to confirm that they
gave the right side foot length for this
longer side so we just use Pythagorean
theorem the length of that size going to
be the square
of this squared plus this squared square
root of 4 plus 25 which equals the
square root of 29 so the size could be
25 square root of 29 and that is choice
a choice B has two and five and then
they give you seven because sue me that
you didn't know how to do the
Pythagorean theorem next problem problem
19 if I want to be able squeeze in let F
be defined by f of X is equal to 2x
minus 1 if one half times F of the
square root of T is equal to 4 what is
the value of T so let's just evaluate
this expression so it's one half times
what f of the square root of T Square
everywhere we see X we stick in the
square root of T so one half that one
half is just this one half right now f
of square root of t is 2 times the
square root of t minus 1 i just replaced
X with square root of T and we know that
this equals 4 let's multiply both sides
by one half and you get or multiply both
sides by to the one-half gets cancelled
out here so you get to square root of t
minus 1 is equal to 8 and you get to
square root of T adding 1 to both sides
is equal to 9 let me continue it here
divide both sides by 2 you get square
root of T is equal to 9 over 2 and now
we can square both sides of this so you
get T is equal to what's 9 over 2
squared it's 81 / 4 and that is choice E
ok and then let's see if i have time i
have 50 seconds let me see if I can
squeeze in video 20 in here if K is a
positive integer which of the following
must represent an even integer that is
twice the value of an odd integer ok so
k is any positive integer so I want an
even number that is twice the value of
an odd integer so an odd integer can be
represented if this is any integer an
odd integer can be represented as 2
times k plus 1 this is definitely going
to be an auditor you can try it out with
one two or three so if I want double
this i just multiply by 2 I get 4k 4k
plus 2 and that is choice E and you can
try it out with some numbers you just
have to take my word that that has to be
an odd integer and then you double it
I'll see in the next section